so let's get started first us some
logistics so homework three is due
tonight
that's the last homework assignment
beyond your your projects and the
project milestone the first milestone or
the only milestone is due next Wednesday
and then after that you will just have
the the poster session and the final
presentation or the final report will be
sending out feedback on your project
proposals within the next few days great
so let's go through the plan for today
so today we talked about model-based
reinforcement learning and how it can be
used for multi task learning and meta
learning and also how it contrasts with
model free learning which is the kind of
reinforcement learning that we've been
talking about thus far in the course
we'll also be talking about how we can
extend model-based reinforcement
learning to image observations or other
high dimensional inputs this is one of a
very challenging use case for
model-based reinforcement learning and
so we'll we'll be covering that in in
more detail and we'll be also talking
about model-based meta reinforcement
learning and settings where that might
be applicable and also just kind of by
the end of this lecture some of the
things that you'll hopefully be able to
learn about are how to understand and
use an implement model-based
reinforcement learning methods
challenges and strategies for
model-based reinforcement learning with
high dimensional inputs and also how
this relates to multi task learning and
meta learning alright so first let's
talk about reinforcement learning
algorithms from a broader view so in
previous lectures we showed this diagram
where we looked at reinforcement
learning as an algorithm that iterates
between generating samples fitting them
all to estimate the return from those
samples and then using that to improve
the policy and we talked about key
learning based methods and policy
gradient based methods that correspond
to estimating the return or fitting a
cue function and in contrast model-based
approaches try to fit a model of the
dynamics and each of these approaches
improve the policy by either applying
the policy gradient by taking a max over
your cue function in order to improve
your policy or to
optimize actions or optimize the
parameters of your policy using your
model so previous lectures we focused on
model free methods like policy gradients
and cue learning and this lecture will
be focusing on what's known as model
based methods and they're known as model
based methods because you're trying to
fit this model of the what's known as
the dynamics model okay so the main idea
of model based reinforcement learning is
to learn a model of the environment and
you might wonder hey why do we want to
do this the previous reinforcement
learning method seemed to work pretty
well too or maybe they don't depending
on on what you found in your project or
in your homework and there's kind of two
main reasons I think at least from I've
seen in terms of my own experiments is
that model-based reinforcement learning
tends to lead to better sample
efficiency so if you care about learning
with not a lot of interactions in the
environment fitting a model of the
environment and then using that model to
optimize your policy can reduce the
amount of data that you need in the
environment this isn't true in all cases
ah but it's true it has at least been
empirically true in a number of
different works and also the model can
be reused for different tasks and
different objectives and we'll talk a
bit about what that means later in the
lecture and so at a high level with this
what these algorithms type are trying to
do is they're trying to estimate
um all of the dynamics and this just
corresponds to a supervised learning
problem where you want to maximize the
likelihood of the next state given the
current state and the current action for
all of the transitions in your buffer of
data so for example you could treat this
if you have continuous states and you
want to model the likelihood using a
Gaussian you could just use the
following optimization problem where you
want to be able to minimize the squared
error between the predictions from your
model and the observed next state this
would be an example of a deterministic
model you could also imagine using
probabilistic or stochastic models as
well that actually try to model that
likelihood well the full distribution of
the likely
okay um and so this is kind of the
there's different ways different moral
classes that you can use in different
different ways that you could go about
maximizing that likelihood but it
typically just amounts to a supervised
learning problem and then once we have
our model we use that to improve our
policy and I'll talk a bit about the
different ways that we can do that in a
minute and then you can use that policy
or use the actions that you optimize to
generate samples and repeat this process
okay so now what does this have to do
with multitask learning and medal
earning so let's go back to our notion
of what a reinforcement learning task is
in a particular we considered this
reinforcement learning task is basically
at Mt P where different tasks may have
different states places different action
spaces different initial State
distributions dynamics and rewards
essentially these House correspondent
MVPs and one kind of observation is that
in many practical scenarios that we
might care about in multi task
reinforcement learning and in meta
reinforcement learning it may be that
the dynamics don't actually vary across
tasks but there's basically one single
dynamics model that governs the governs
the world that your agent is living in
and if this is true then we may be able
to kind of exploit that property so for
example in the real world if your agent
is manipulating objects or if it is
walking around on the ground or if it is
navigating an environment the dynamics
of the world of the underlying world for
manipulating different for doing
different things with different objects
for getting somewhere in the environment
through locomotion or through navigation
and all these settings the underlying
dynamics of the world isn't necessarily
changing of course when the environment
is fully observed and you can't fully
observed physical physical information
about the objects are about locomotion
then there may be some variation across
across tasks or across objects I'm
another example of this is character
animation so if you want to animate a
character to do things like spin clicks
spin cakes or cartwheels or
running or backflipping all of these
that this agent lives in a single world
with consistent dynamics and what's
varying is just the reward function and
not the dynamics and likewise if you
have an agent that wants to converse and
accomplish a certain task through
dialogue such as helping you order
dinner for example or helping you
reserve a car reservation or something
the underlying dynamics of interacting
with that person may be the same but the
reward function of what you want to
accomplish is varying so here are a few
examples of where the dynamics might be
consistent across tasks in all of these
cases estimating the model as a single
task problem if there's just a single
model we only need to estimate a single
function and so as a result then this
learning problem may actually be easier
than some of the multi task model free
methods because we only have to solve
the single task learning problem and
then once we solve that single test
learning problem we can use that to find
a policy that optimizes different tasks
any questions on on this okay so how do
we actually go about using our model to
optimize for actions so we want to be
able to kind of optimize actions using
the model and our objective might be to
maximize our reward summed over time and
so one way that we might think about
doing this is we can view this this form
of computation graph where we have
actions being passed into our model our
model is predicting the next state which
is producing the reward function and
also producing sorry the up model is
estimating the reward function it may
also be estimating the next state which
is then passed to our policy to produce
the next action and the next reward
function and so if we want to optimize
over the sequence of actions that
maximize our reward we could imagine
just back propagating the signal from
our reward function into our actions do
this computation graph and so for
example we could use a gradient based
optimization over our actions
optimize for our actions so what this
might look like is you might run some
policy for example a random policy I
collect some data using that policy and
then fit a model to that data to
minimize the the prediction error of
that model and then back propagate
through that model in order to optimize
for a sequence of actions and then once
you have those actions you can just
execute those actions to accomplish the
task that you liked it before so this is
pretty straightforward another way that
we could do this is say say we don't
want to use back propagation for example
maybe the model that we learn is doesn't
have well condition gradients or maybe
it's discontinuous in some way we can
also optimize the reactions via sampling
and this would be essentially a gradient
free optimization over our actions same
still the same underlying loss function
the same underlying optimization we can
just use a different optimization
approach for acquiring a sequence of
actions that will maximize reward and so
what this might look like is to run some
policy learn a model to minimize model
error and then iteratively sample action
sequences run those action sequences
through our model and the action
sequence we find achieves the best
reward
we will then execute those corresponding
actions and there ways to to sample
action sequences in a more intelligent
way so you can imagine just sampling
from some uniform distribution of our
action sequences and then taking the
best one we could also imagine after
sampling from a uniform distribution you
could take the best ten percent for
example rather than the best one and
then refit a distribution around those
ten around those top ten percent of
actions and resample from that
distribution and do this sort of
iterative process to iteratively refine
the sampling distribution over actions
that would be known as something like
the cross-entropy method and that would
allow you to perform a slightly better
optimization or a slightly better
slightly more powerful optimization over
your actions okay so here are a couple
different approaches what's something
that might go wrong with these
approaches
any thoughts on that mm-hmm yeah so if
your reward function is sparse and your
optimization process isn't able to
sample action sequences that lead to
that reward or let that actually see any
reward then it may be that your
optimization won't be powerful enough to
actually find a good sequence of actions
that's one good example what's another
good example yeah yeah so in both of
these cases you need to solve an
optimization problem in order to get a
sequence of actions that will that will
try to maximize that reward sorry can
you repeat that yeah absolutely so if
your model
I guess says I think there's two things
here one is if your model is inaccurate
then the optimization can exploit that
and and be overly optimistic about
whether or not an action sequence will
accomplish high reward and the second
thing is that if you're optimizing for
an open-loop sequence of actions and
then executing that sequence of actions
if one of those actions reaches a state
that's slightly different from what you
thought you would reach and then at the
next state you actually another action
you'll have these compounding errors
such that you move away from the
trajectory that you that you thought you
were going to follow according to your
model okay any other thoughts on what
might go wrong okay cool so the approach
that that I had written here was I guess
there's a couple couple different things
that we discussed the first is that you
can potentially have imprecisions in
your model and that will cause you to to
kind of be overly optimistic about what
will happen and second that these errors
can compound and cause you to kind of go
off track
it have increasing amounts of errors as
you roll out your as you roll out your
sequence of actions one thing that will
help with this actually Jenny if you
have thoughts on like how we might try
to avoid some of these issues or these
two issues in particular yep yeah so the
the key thing is the second part that
you said is that if that turned out not
to be true we need to actually take that
into account right also in the algorithm
that I listed on the previous slide
we're actually just fitting a model to
our data and then executing actions
according to that data but if we turn
out if it turns out then we take those
actions and it was actually not the
correct thing to do as you're mentioning
then we should basically refit our model
using the new data and use that to
continuously improve our model in the
settings where we were overly optimistic
and so what you can do is you can go
back to this previous algorithm and then
actually execute those planned actions
in the world append the data that you
observed to your data set and use that
to refit your model to this growing data
set does that answer your question
the sorry you're asking the so if you
make an overly optimistic decision it
can certainly if that is like if you're
if you're like done running learning and
you're not going to actually collect any
more data then that can be very bad
because you'll just you won't actually
be making predictions that maximize
reward it can be arbitrarily bad if it's
like erroneous outside of the the states
that you visited but if you have the
ability to collect more data than you in
principle should be able to correct for
those errors okay so this is this is one
thing that we can do but still even if
so this will help
certainly I doesn't completely solve the
problem so in general learning a good
global model is pretty hard especially
if you want to learn a good global model
everywhere in your in all possible
states for example another trick that
can be helpful with this is what's
called replanting so and this is a
fancier name for this is model
predictive control or MPC and what we
can do is we can first run our policy to
collect some data fit a model to that
data use a small to optimize it for
action sequence no we can do is we can
execute the first planned action observe
the resulting state append this to our
data set and then after we take once one
action we can that actually replan and
reoptimize over a sequence of actions
from the state that we just observed and
so what this can do is that if you end
up at a state that you didn't expect as
a result of your model you won't keep on
executing actions as if you were in the
state that you thought you would reach
you'll bet actually replan according to
the state that you actually reached try
to correct for your mistake at that
first time step and so this can help
address some of the compounding errors
that we talked about before yeah
yeah so we haven't gotten to the
meta-learning setting yet but you could
also imagine so in this setting there
might be a loop here which is to kind of
refit your model in this like slower
outer loop in here all the only thing
that you're doing is you're observing
this state and then using your model to
replan to like reoptimize action
sequences from that state you're not
actually so you're using that to update
your actions you're not actually using
it to update your model and you could
also imagine using that state to update
your model and we'll get to that
actually at the like towards the end of
the lecture so you're a few steps ahead
so intuitively this can help with model
errors because it can a lot if you kind
of go off track of where where your
model thinks you will end up you can in
principle start to crouch for those so
the the benefit of this is you can
correct some model errors one of the
downsides of this approach which i think
was maybe alluded to in one of the other
questions is that this is in general
planning for actions is a fairly
compute-intensive process because you
need to continuously I mean if you're
planning at every single time step
you're doing an optimization you need to
do an optimization in real time one
thing that can help with this is to
optimize over instead of optimize over a
sequence of actions you could actually
back propagate actions into your policy
so if you have a parametric form of your
policy instead of back prepping great
gradients into the action you can back
propagate gradients into the policy
parameters
likewise for a sampling based approach
if you optimize for a sequence of
actions you could use those as targets
to train a policy to produce those
actions and that can reduce some of the
compute-intensive challenges of things
like MTC now I also want to get back to
the problem of sparse rewards that was
mentioned learning a policy can also
help with sparse rewards in that if you
in aggregate at some point you see a
good reward function or a good reward
than your policy the policy parameters
will be trained to try to accomplish
those in practice like with
very sparse Awards model-based
optimization and model free optimization
will run into the same sorts of issues
if they don't actually ever observe
rewards and things like relabeling as
you saw in the problem assignment can
also help with that okay any questions
on kind of the basic algorithms before
we talk about the multitasking yeah so I
actually haven't heard that argument
before so the argument you said is that
there are behaviors that will emerge
with model-free that you won't be able
to have emerged with a model-based
method yeah I don't actually see why
that would be the case like in both
cases you are you're optimizing some
objective which is to maximize reward
and the behavior that emerges like in
both cases you are going to be learning
some behavior to maximize that reward
function and I think that what comes out
of that optimization is more function of
this the power how powerful that
optimization process is and if it's if
you have a very strong optimization
process then more interesting well and a
reward function that's interesting then
more interesting behaviors will emerge
and I don't think that there's any
difference I think that like any
difference that you see in the outcome
of these model of these approaches will
more have to do with the strength of the
optimization and also how hard is to fit
them all versus fitting a policy there
are definitely settings where it's
harder to fit the model than to fit the
policy so for example if you want to
pour water from one container to another
container modeling fluid dynamics is a
hard problem but just twisting your arm
is a relatively simple function to learn
and those settings a model free approach
may be easier in other settings such as
if you want to be able to
you push an object to any possible
position the dynamics may be relatively
simple because it just corresponds to
one object on the table and the dynamics
there whereas the policy may be more
complex because for any pasta you have
to represent the policy for any possible
goal whereas the dynamic service is just
a single task problem okay so we can
look at that what does this actually
look like and we use it this question
about like what does this have to do
with multitask our land and meta are L
so how you actually apply this to the
multitask RL and meta RL problem
statement depends on whether or not you
know the reward function and in
particular there are some instances we
actually know the form of the reward
function exactly
so we'll see an example of this in a
second and if you know the reward
function in for each task then you could
just learn a single model and plan with
respect to that reward function at each
at test time so for example here's an
example of a work that was done by a new
should Naga Bondi and colleagues and
what they were looking at is they wanted
to learn how to write different
trajectories with a pen and they were
controlling the the hand in simulation
and different Ward functions correspond
to different trajectories of the tip of
the pencil and so in this case they
assumed that they could observe the tip
of the pencil and then the reward
function can be derived as just trying
to track a particular trajectory with
the tip of the pencil so the form of the
reward function is known but optimizing
that the reward function I by actually
using the hand to draw is a very
challenging problem and so they learned
a model and actually learn to model by
collecting data with respect to random
trajectories and then at test time they
gave it reward functions for writing
different digits it's a little bit hard
to see I think the first digit is a six
the second one is a seven the next one
is like a nine or a four and the last
one is a five and you can basically use
that model to plan to accomplish these
different these different trajectories
another example of this is maybe you
want the hand to be able to manipulate
these bounding
like move them in a circle for example
here the reward function is also known
it corresponds to the trajectory of the
of the two balls and you can also have a
reward function corresponding to moving
the ball to a particular location in
that in the palm or also rotating the
balls in the opposite direction cool so
here here's an example of kind of
multitask reinforcement learning with a
single model and different reward
functions one caveat that I'd like to
mention here is that even though the
dynamics may be consistent across all of
the tasks different tasks may require
you to visit different state
distributions and so if you collect data
for one task and another task is a very
different state distribution then the
model that you learn for that one task
may not actually generalize to the
second task if it doesn't visit the the
same States so the reward may change how
you collect the data and may affect the
quality of your model in other states in
this work they found that if you
actually train a model only on this
first task that model can actually be
reused for the second two tasks because
the distribution over States is
sufficiently diverse um in this case the
state representation corresponds to the
position of the two balls and the state
information about the hands such as the
joint angles I'm not I'm actually
thinking about this more a bit more I'm
not quite sure how they go from two
balls to one ball because the state
representation changes in that case I
would guess that maybe they just used
the the model of corresponding to one of
the balls and that you ignore the second
one but I I'd have to check the details
of the paper for that it's possible that
they're different sizes I my impression
was that they were the same size and
maybe the the videos actually so the
hand is also bigger in the left video so
I think it's just that the video has
been scaled differently
another cool thing about this approach
is that because it's able to learn a
model
pretty quickly with a relatively small
amount of data they actually were able
to run this method on a real robot and
actually run the reinforced learning
process and collect all the data on a
real robot and fit a model to that and
we're able to get a real shot out hand
to perform this task cool yeah it's
actually pretty recent work well so I
I'm I know India well so I've seen it
for a while but I think that the video
came out like within the last month it
was published at quarrel which was last
week which is why I was actually not
here yep okay cool so that's what
happens if we know the reward function
what if we don't know the reward
function or the at least the form of the
reward function one thing we can do is
we could just learn a reward function I
conditioned on the task and then use
that reward function to plan to
accomplish tasks and I have a typo on
the next thing but this should say meta
RL the only thing that you could do is
you could medal earn a reward function
from a small amount of data and use that
to use that learn reward function to
plan to accomplish goals this is pretty
straightforward one example of the
second case is some work here where the
the training dataset corresponds to a
few examples of the goal so in this case
the goal is to place the the pencil case
too on top of the or behind the notebook
and given a few positive examples you
want to be able to learn a classifier or
a binary reward function that
corresponds to whether or not the task
has been accomplished in the image and
so you can you can do this house with
meta training but by met with meta
learning by collecting a data set of a
bunch of positive and negative examples
for different tasks metod learn your
classifiers such that given a small
number of positive examples it can
quickly learn a new reward function and
then once you have their or word
function you can plan using your model
to maximize reward so here's the kind of
the result of running planning and then
executing those actions on the robot to
accomplish the task with respect to this
meta learned reward function
okay and I guess the kind of thing the
bigger take away here is that model
based RL solves both the multitask RL
problem and the meta RL problem
statements with these with these
different types of approaches depending
on whether or not you have their award
function or not okay any questions
before we move on to image observations
so one thing worth mentioning here they
didn't actually tell you is that this is
this is all from images and so how do we
actually go about doing mahalo based RL
when we have image observations right so
in particular if you only have access to
images you might have a graphical model
like this where you can't actually
observe the underlying state the low
dimensional underlying state of the
world and you can only observe the O's
shown here so for example maybe you have
a robot that looks like this and you
want to be able to use the spatula to
lift up an object and put it into the
bowl and all I can observe is this image
so first with with these images you have
to deal with learning models in in in
some space at least and learning how to
predict and second we also don't have
any reward function necessarily if we
only have those observations and so we
need to think about how we might go
about learning a reward function such as
using the meta learning approach that I
showed on did previously okay so one
option for the reward function is to
learn the image classifier like I showed
before or to medal learning an image
classifier another example or another
option is to provide an image of the
goal and this would correspond to the
goal conditioned reinforcement learning
setting that we have covered previously
and that you looked at in your homework
and so for example you could give the
the robot an image of the goal like this
saying I want you to accomplish this
this goal state and have it try to to
reach that goal state so how might we go
about doing model-based RL in this
setting so there's a few different
classes of approaches that we'll cover
the first is to learn some latent
representation and then learn a model in
that late and representation the second
is to try to learn a model of your
observations directly and the last one
is to try to predict alternative
quantities other than your raw
observations and we'll talk about all
three of these approaches so first let's
talk about latent space so the key idea
of learning in the light in space is
that you want to learn to some embedding
of your observations we're told to use
denote as G of O and then learn a model
inside that embedding space so if we
take the graphical model that we showed
before this corresponds to trying to
learn some form of inference network
that maps from your observations to your
bacterial low dimensional States we're
back to some representation of your
state space so then kind of the way this
works I guess is first there's a couple
papers that have looked at this kind of
approach so here that we'll talk about
and there more recently there are a
couple of other approaches that have
looked at this kind of approach as well
so I'm the way that this algorithm works
is first you run some policy to collect
some data then you learn this latent
space of your observation and a model in
that latent space so you'll learn a G to
go from o to s and then you'll learn a
model that goes from s and a to predict
s prime then you use your model to
optimize over a sequence of actions and
then execute those pantac planned
actions append the visiting tuples in
this case it may be the the state an
action the next state or might be the
observation the action and the next
observation and then you can add those
tuples and then re retrain your
embedding space and retrain your your
model okay so this is pretty
straightforward
there are a couple questions though the
first question is what is your reward
function when you're trying to optimize
over your actions so we talked a little
bit about how your reward function could
correspond to a classifier in the case
where you're given an image of the goal
one thing you can do is you can use your
signal as some rewards signal of your
actions such as trying to minimize
effort or torque plus a distance
function and that's there should be a
negative sign in front of that at some
distance some negative distance between
the goal of your current observation and
sorry the representation of your current
observation and the representation of
your goal observation so you can
basically use the negative distance in
your latent space as a reward function
for planning okay and this makes the
assumption that distance distance in
your latent space is an accurate metric
for the things that you care about and
this this assumption may or may not be
true depending on the form of your lane
representation okay and then the second
big question or maybe the most salient
question is how to actually get this
latent representation space there's a
couple of different people approaches
that people have taken to try to do this
one of the more popular approaches that
we looked at in 2015 and also actually
more recently is to try to form a
graphical model of your transitions and
this basically corresponds to a
variational auto encoder that looks at
transitions over pairs of states rather
than a single variational auto encoder
for a single state and as a result what
you get is you're optimizing jointly for
the latent representation of your
variational auto encoder for example as
well as the transition distribution your
model in that latent space and so if you
do this you can kind of get an get a
representation space that it's good both
that is both low dimensional as well as
satisfies your model effectively and so
for example they showed that you could
use this use the algorithm with this
latent space for accomplishing different
kinds of goals so the goal image was
shown on at the beginning of the video
and then in each case it's trying to
reach its executing actions that try to
reach that image so we'll see another
example in a minute so here the goal
state is to curl up the arm
and the left is showing the executed
actions and the right is showing the
one-step predictions of the
reconstructed image through that
directive model and so one of the things
you can see is that it can use a single
model and a certain a single layer
representation to accomplish these
different goals the other thing worth
mentioning is I kind of alluded to at
the beginning of this lecture that the
model based methods tend to be fairly
efficient this approach required about
300 trials to learn these these skills
from the pixel representations which if
you were to run that in the real world
would probably correspond to about 25
minutes of real time which is pretty
fast as reinforcement learning goes in
practice some of the more recent model
free methods take around two to three
hours to learn yeah um
there are couple more we said where
solar is one of them there's also
stochastic dr. critic which is covered
more recently that one's kind of more of
a hybrid method but also has this form
of graphical model yeah yeah yeah so the
question is this method and some of the
the predecessors or successors of this
method place this assumption on the
latent space which is that you can
linearly or you can basically have a
local linear model on that space that
could accurately predict the next state
given the current state where local
means that you may have a time varying
linear model I think that theoretically
speaking if you have a universal
function approximator that's producing
your state it seems like it should it
should be possible to learn the latent
space that is that does actually satisfy
that constraint in practice it may be
that may be very difficult optimization
problem to actually find that that
latent space
and we haven't yet seen these kinds of
methods perform well on very diverse
settings where you have many different
objects in the scene and and and kind of
the kind of diversity and complexity
that you see in like natural images and
and and and in like image and images for
example uh that is actually oh I'll come
back to that point in a second as well
as we talked about kind of modeling and
land space versus modeling an
observation space yeah yes
planet planet is also learning a latent
representation and doing planning in
that representation the planning
approach that they use member the exact
details of which planning approach they
use I think it actually may have
correspond to a model free algorithm
sorry what oh okay right okay yeah so is
using right okay so he's using
cross-entropy method which is the
basically the iterative sampling based
approach that we talked about planet
planet is also kind of has a very
similar form of this graph kamal
although in addition to having the
stochastic pathway they also had a
deterministic pathway in their model the
planet to my knowledge wasn't tested in
the multitask case it was just tested in
the single-task case but in principle
that the model that's learned could also
be used in the multi table setting
yeah so there's been a number of
approaches recently that have kind of
followed this form of kind of learning a
late in space with some sort of
probabilistic or semi probabilistic
approach and then doing learning in that
latent space one another example of a
latent space that that we used in 2016
and also was actually it has been
studied a bit more recently as well is
having representations that are have
structure to them so in this case the
structure that we were looking at were
latent spaces where the the dimensions
of the light and space correspond to key
points in the image so for example here
are two example to example key points
that are in there
presentation and this is the trajectory
that that representation follows as the
robot executes strictly and this more
recently there's been a kind of a trend
over approaches that try to learn object
centric representations or key point
based representations of images and then
perform planning or perform model-based
RL in the context of those
representations and so this is kind of
maybe I'll an alternative view I think
that both of them have their merits and
I guess specifically for this this
approach the way that you actually try
to get those feature points is you can
take the last convolutional layer of
your network perform a soft max over the
spatial extent of the image to get a
distribution over 2d positions in the
image and then once you have it all
these distributions over key points you
can then here's an example the softmax
for the softbox is over the x position
and the y position then you can take an
expectation where you compute the an
expectation over that 2d distribution to
get the XY coordinate of the of the of
approximately the the key point of
maximal activation so you can
essentially view this as a form of like
spatial softmax so instead of doing a
soft max over a one-dimensional
operation you can do a soft max over a
2d space and get some a key point out of
it and of course I guess the important
part is that this operation is actually
fully differentiable so you can optimize
for these kinds of representations with
respect to the objective that you care
about be it things like reconstruction
or something like the objective of your
task and there are also other kind of
more recent approaches that have looked
at kind of other other ways of getting
like these key point like
representations or object centric
representations and unsupervised ways or
in like weekly supervised points and so
what the result that you get out of this
is if you train it to do reconstruction
here are two of the future points that
you might get out of it out of the in
this case the sixteen feature points
that were used okay and I guess there's
also I said smooth here because there's
also an auxilary loss to encourage these
representations to be have to have
similar to have constant velocity
through time I think that that detail is
maybe a little bit less important yeah
yeah so in this case the number of
feature points the number of total
feature points need to be predefined as
part of your network network
architecture so in this case the number
of feature points is is 16 in the
dimensionality is 16 times 2 one thing
you could imagine doing that we actually
did explore in this paper as well as
have a larger number of feature points
and then prune the future points
according to something metric for
example according to if some feature
points noobs are be very noisy then you
could prune those feature points out if
you don't think that they correspond to
in an automatic way if you don't think
they correspond to things relevant to
the task yeah so in this case it was a
completely unsupervised setting so the
the goal this auto encoder was it's an
auto encoder so it was is its losses to
reconstruct the image it needs to find
these 2d key points that allow it to
reconstruct the image and because
different images have different
positions of objects then extracting the
positions of objects or actually
extracting the positions of things that
change and move in the image lead to
good reconstructions so essentially just
a constraint on your latent space to
have to have it be representing these
treating positions and how it uses that
that representation space is up to the
model yeah so occlusions is challenging
one thing you could imagine doing is
having a recurrent model and then the
recurrent modeling principle could try
to track it and this work one of the
things we did to deal with occlusions
was we used a filtering based approach
we basically did a form of filtering
where you can basically look at that the
softmax distribution if it's very
heat then it's likely that the point is
in view if it's not peeked then it's
likely that the point is occluded and if
it is occluded then you can actually use
your model to fill in like a common
filter style update to fill in where you
think that point is yeah so there's a
lot of potential details here that I
wasn't planning to cover but it's yeah
there's different things that you could
imagine doing another challenge with
this type of approach like that I guess
is worth mentioning is that if you have
two objects that are identical
this softmax sense is over the entire
extent of the image it's going to have
two peaks if they look identical and
therefore if you take the expectation
then you'll either get the average I'll
get you'll get the point that dominates
or you might get this flickering between
the two points and so there isn't
necessarily a satisfying way to deal
with that yeah this is actually from
2016 so the paper reference is there so
here's an example of the learning
process so we actually in this work we
gave it both the goal image as well as
the goal position of the arm we
initialized it with a policy that could
that could reach the position the goal
position of the arm but not the goal
image and then this is the course of
model-based reinforcement learning
whereas in this case is actually
optimizing for a policy that tries to
reach both the goal image and the goal
position of the arm and this is a toy
task where the gold positions are the
goal position is just to reach to push
the cube over to the left and then the
final policy you get looks something
like this where it's able to push it to
the specified position on the on the mat
the colors actually seem off this is
supposed to be green but anyway then you
could also perform the task that the
special task that I showed before where
the goal is to get the spatula to be in
the bowl cool so one of the nice things
about this approach also with these
sorts of key point based representations
I don't I guess I'm spending more time
on the key point based representations
but I don't think there's less
certainly one approaches a slide better
than the other but one thing that is
quite convenient about this is you can
actually visualize the key points on the
image so in this case the X's correspond
to the goal position and the blue and
the circles correspond to the current
position of the key points and you can
with this ability to visualize them
directly on the image it makes for a
very interpretable representation and
this is very useful for debugging
because if your representation isn't
capturing and isn't tracking the objects
that you care about then it's likely
that your algorithm won't work because
your representation isn't capturing
those things yeah yes the key points are
the laden representation okay so these
skills were learned with about 125
trials which corresponds to about 11
minutes of robot time per task in this
case the representation was actually
learned per environment or per task so
it's kind of learning this environment
specific latent representation and so as
a result the representations can become
somewhat specific to that environment
and so for example if you took this
these representations and try to use it
for a different task like the Lego block
toss they wouldn't necessarily track the
objects because they weren't trained on
those images okay cool so one thought
exercise so both of the approaches that
we looked at were otto and clara type
approaches like generative models where
we're predicting the the image we're
trying to generate the image through
some ball neck and we may also be
learning a model on that bottleneck so
one question is why do we need to
reconstruct the image right why not just
learn some embedding space like the
feature points and then also learn a
model on those feature points and train
the representation such that the mall is
accurate this seems like somewhat of a
reasonable approach why is this maybe
not a good approach
optimizing with respect to model error
for the representation what actually is
actually definitely a solvable problem
right so the embedding does depend on
the problem that you're solving and so
if you're optimizing with respect to
model error then it it may not capture
it'll capture things about the model and
not necessarily about the task yeah yeah
there's actually also problem with that
yeah it's definitely problem it's also
actually a problem with reconstruction
based approaches and we'll see that in a
second yeah mm-hmm and so what does that
what does that mean
mmm and so what happens if you optimize
for both the embedding on the model with
respect to the error of the bottle sorry
what yes
yeah so there is a solution to this so
this this but it's basically to the mall
error objective which is that if you're
embedding is always the same thing if
it's a constant if it's like always zero
for example then it's perfectly it's
very easy to predict the next date right
because it's just always zero and then
as a result I mean that embedding isn't
very useful because it's a constant it's
always zero but it achieves perfect
model error so there's basically this
degenerate solution that comes up if you
try to optimize with respect to model
error but for both the embedding and the
model so it's not really a good idea so
this is why we need kind of other other
forms of objectives to optimize for
these representations in addition to
model error so that you can avoid that
degenerate solution okay does that make
sense yeah so that's actually an
interesting point so if you add an
entropy term interestingly that will
actually correspond to maximizing the
mutual information between your
representation and your your observation
so the I don't well if you if you want
to maximize your mutual information
between your image observation and your
latent representation you can show that
this is equal to H of Z minus H of Z
given s and so this would correspond to
maximize the entropy like you said and
this would correspond to being able to
predict Z from s and so that's actually
a pretty good thing to do and a lot of
people have looked at these types of
objectives for learning
patience cool so to wrap up the Leighton
space approaches the benefits of this
approach is that you can learn pretty
complex skills very efficiently and some
structure to structure representations
and able very effective learning at
these tasks the downsides is that is one
of the main down sizes that we need good
objectives for learning these
representations and things like
reconstruction objectives may not
actually recover the right
representation so as an example of this
when I was doing those experiments a few
years ago with the spatula task we also
wanted the robot to do another task
which was to manipulate a ping-pong ball
by like basically like kind of
transferring it from one container to
another container and so here's a
downsampled image of of that experiment
where the white dot corresponds to the
ping-pong ball and you can see the arm
of the robot as well and so I trained an
autoencoder on these images and the
reconstructions that I got out of it
looked like this and so what you can see
is that it learns to learns a very good
eraser of the ping-pong ball and instead
just learns to reconstruct the arm
because that's the thing that's larger
in the image and so there's this
mismatch between the objective of the
representation learning and the
objective of the task that you might
care about so kind of the takeaway here
is that we may need better on supervised
representation learning methods be a
reconstruction based on methods or like
mutual information based objectives okay
and then one other side note is that low
dimensional embeddings can be also be
very useful for model free approaches so
for example you could learn a low
dimensional embedding and doom all three
in that latent space mafia realm that
layton space so there's work back in
2012 that did this for this slot car
where they trained an autoencoder and
then two down to a two dimensional
representation and then did fitted cue
iteration on top of that two dimensional
representation and this work actually
predates things like dqn so they're
doing deep RL back in back in 2012
here's an approach that was able to run
T RPO which is typically an algorithm
that requires
a very large number of samples but they
learned too late in space of actually
both the state and the actions and we're
able to run TR Pio on a real robot to
throw an object to hit the Pikachu and
then there are also methods that use an
embedding for the reward function so we
talked a little bit about how and the
previous approaches we're using the
embedding both for the state
representation and for the reward
representation in this case this work
was looking at acquiring a reward
function from imagenet features so this
is actually a supervised representation
learning method they took they took a
video of a human opening a door ran that
through image net and then use that as a
reward function for a robot to try to
reach the same features that the that
the video on the left was was reaching
and then one other thing worth
mentioning is that you have if you have
a reward you could actually predict it
to form a better late in space and this
can this is one way to kind of help
solve that degenerate solution
degenerates solution that we observed if
you just try to predict model error and
there are a number of approaches that
have looked into that as well one reason
why you may not want to predict forward
is that maybe that you don't have a good
reward function so in the case of the
spatula in the case of the embed to
control paper if you just have goal
images we don't actually have reward
functions but if you do have a reward
function it's it's good to try to use it
okay now that we've talked about latent
space models let's talk about modeling
things directly in your observation
space so we can recall the tetherball
based RL approaches that you mentioned
before in this case this is just the the
same MPC algorithm that I showed before
but where all the states are replaced
with our observations oh and what we can
do is we can learn a model on our
observations and plan with that model so
first we you want to run some policy to
collect some data so for example we
collect data that looks like this this
is just robots randomly interacting with
with objects picking them up and such
and then the data corresponds to the
images
and actions and so it's very easy to
collect data like this you don't need
reward functions you can just run run
off your your robot or your agent and in
whatever environment then you can learn
a model to minimize friction error and
so this corresponds to a video
prediction model so you may get
predictions that look like this for
different actions that are run through
your model also because we're we're not
imposing an e representation on our on
our state we can also apply these sorts
of models to deformable objects because
we're just predicting our raw sensory
observations and then once you have that
model we can use that model to optimize
over actions by actually sampling
shrekface model and picking the actions
that we think will accomplish our goal
this is pretty straightforward
there are a couple challenges though
which is that we need to learn these
models which are pretty challenging to
learn and we need to be able to learn
models by optimizing through these large
video prediction models so first
question how do we actually predict
video we want to learn this model this
is a fairly complex model because it's a
model of how images transform as a
consequence of our actions so this is a
problem that people have actually been
studying for a little while now maybe
five 10 years at least I'll go back in
in 2016 it turned out that the models
were pretty bad so some one of the
example of a model that works a bit
better is something that looks like this
so this is just a big neural network
because of the main points is that it's
it's deep neural network and it's
recurrent and each of these each of the
yellow errors corresponds to a
recurrence and each of the green boxes
and blue boxes correspond to
convolutions it's performing multiple
multiple multi frame prediction so it's
predicting multiple frames into the
future its conditioning on actions so
the actions are passed in here as well
as any state information that you might
have about like the position of the
robots arm and then the only thing about
this model is actually explicitly
modeling the motion of pics
so rather than actually trying to
generate pixels directly like having the
neural network output pixels pixel
values what this model is doing is that
it's taking the previous image it's
predicting actually multiple convolution
curls and then applying those
convolution kernels to the image to
generate multiple transformations of
that image and then composing those
transformed images with these also
predicted masks into a single image
prediction
so essentially predicting the motion of
basically picking how the previous image
will transform into the next image in a
way that's differentiable that can be
back propagated through and so here are
some examples of some videos from a
robot and if you took some of the models
back in in 2015 for example you would
get models that look like this or
predictions that look like this which
don't look very good whereas if you have
recurrent models that are pretty
multiple frames and are explicitly
modeling motion you get predictions that
look much cleaner still blurrier and in
general the video frictions that we're
getting out of these models even in in
2019 so leave some to be desired but
they're still things that we found can
be useful for control yeah yeah so let's
talk about the let's talk about the
planning approach so once we have our
model we need to actually optimize an
action sequence so the way that you can
do this is basically with the sampling
based optimization that we described
previously so say this is our initial
image we consider potential action
sequences it's probably like 100 or a
couple hundred action sequences
including these two action sequences
then predict the future for each action
sequence by running those actions to
your model to get video versions that
look like this and then you can pick the
future that you like the best and
execute the corresponding action or
instead of picking the best one you
could also iteratively resample and then
pick the best one and then what you do
is you could actually repeat these first
three steps in real time in order to
replan and I can do MVC and basically to
this plan
every single time step we found that
this is something that is practical to
do but in the context of with video
picture models it can be a bit slow so
the sampling based approach corresponds
to rolling out these big convolutional
neural networks and rolling out about
set batches of like 100 or hundreds of
action sequences and so as a result the
the time it takes to plan can be on the
order of one hurt for example depending
on how many GPUs you paralyze over that
one hurt would probably be like
paralyzed across like two to four GPUs
okay um so you essentially this is MPC
but in visual space just like visual MPC
okay so that's kind of how you can do
these sorts of mala by star all methods
in the raw observation space the way
that it works at test time is you can
you need to specify some goal there are
a few different ways that you can
specify goals as we talked about before
you could learn an image classifier you
could you could provide an image of the
goal one of the things that we did in
some of this work is specify the goal by
clicking on a pixel and clicking on
where that pixel should be moved to so
for example in this case the goal would
be to fold the left pant leg of these
shorts by moving the red pixel to the
green pixel and then we also specify
another pixel right here to specify that
the pants should stay in place if
they're not if they're not part of the
folding part so once you have this goal
you can run MPC with respect to this
specified goal and then this is the
video friction corresponding to the
action plan that was found by MPC and
then execute the corresponding action on
the robot to try to accomplish that goal
and so here's an example of what the
robot can try to accomplish by with the
respect of the goal of moving the pixel
upward okay and so getting back to the
kind of multitask learning aspect of
model-based are one of the things that
you can do is you can use the single
video picture model to accomplish
multiple tasks so
for example if your goal is to pick up
an object you can click on object click
on where you want to move and then robot
can figure out how to pick it up also if
you want to manipulate the sleeve of a
shirt I can figure that out or like a
task like putting an apple onto a plate
and then we can also look at a few other
examples like folding the shore it's
like rearranging objects or like
covering an object with a towel yeah so
one of the nice things about this is
that it allows us to accomplish many
different goals are many different Ward
functions with a single model without
having to retrain our model for every
single task and the only nice thing
about this is that the model training
part is self supervised you don't need
to provide reward functions or
supervision the robot can count just
collect data and train them all on that
data okay so the benefits of this kind
of approach is that this was able to
scale to real images fairly effectively
there's also very limited human
involvement and so the model training
was fully self supervised and this was
also able to accomplish many different
tasks with a single model these pros are
also shared with many of the latent
spaced approaches as well although in
practice we've found that Layton's based
approaches have trouble modeling some of
that I don't some of the diversity of
the videos like this because you have to
capture all those objects that you might
see in a compact plane in space and some
of the downsides is that despite the
fact that they're real images there's
somewhat limited background variability
so this is more variability than like
the spatula example for example but
still less variability to things like
imagenet for example you can't have
can't yet handle as complex skills as
the spatula example for example these
are just pick and play style tasks and
it's also very compute intensive that
test time ok any questions on how that
works
okay um what are their quick asides I
think we have a bit of time is how can
we think about actually doing more
complex skills rather than things like
pick in place and one thing you could
imagine doing as we talked about before
is using your planner to collect more
data and then using that data it to
improve your model and I would expect
something like that to perform pretty
well I'll go and practice one of the
challenges with that is if your planner
is very compute-intensive
then it may be very expensive to collect
more data using your model so one
approach that we've looked at in the
context of this work is if we can
incorporate some forms of supervision
such as demonstrations in order to learn
more complex skills so what you could do
is you could collect demonstrations from
many different tasks and potentially use
those demonstrations to improve the
complexity of skills that you could
learn with this approach I am pretty
clear there's a few different ways that
you could use these demonstrations the
first is to append it to your dataset
and use them to improve your model but
you can also use it to improve the other
two approaches as well so what you can
do is you could fit a model to the
behavior of the demonstrator to
basically predict the kinds of actions
that the demonstrator might take based
on an initial image and if you have this
model of the kinds of tasks that are
interesting to perform then you can use
this to first elect your data collection
process towards the more interesting
kinds of behaviors and the more
interesting tasks and you can also use
it to guide the planning process so if
you know that you could be doing kind of
a task that is that may resemble some of
the tasks that you saw in the
demonstrations then you can sample
actions similar to the actions that the
human would would take in addition to
the actions that you would sample from
some random distribution so an example
of this is that I won one setting where
we say this problem is in the example
where you want to have a robot
manipulate tools so here are some
examples of the demonstrations that that
the user collected
I've using different tools to push them
in different ways here are some examples
of the samples from the actor proposal
ball so this is kind of the the types of
actions that the robot thinks that the
user might perform so these correspond
to kind of grasping towards objects and
moving those objects these these actions
are actually passed through the video
picture model so these are actually
videos but these are actions I think
might be interesting I've passed you the
very picture model and then what you can
do is that you can specify your goal as
before then run planning guided by that
action proposal model with this puck to
your goal to get a prediction that looks
like this and a sequence of actions that
corresponds to this video and then
execute those actions on the robot to
get to try to accomplish the goal in the
bottom in the top left ok
so I'm actually incorporating these
diverse demonstrations were allowed the
robot is allowed it can now kind of
perform these more complex tasks that
involve grasping an object and then
using that object to perform the task
rather than just pick and place tasks
and pushing tasks okay and again because
the the model is trained on a diverse
set of objects and tasks and because the
demonstrations are also diverse it means
that the single model is reusable for
these different kinds of tasks so the
ball can be used to solve tasks that
weren't seen in the demonstrations such
as using a broom to push objects into a
dustpan it can be used for trying to
like use a hook to bring out of reach
objects closer to the robot so in this
case the the robot was constrained to
move in that green shaded region such
that it actually had to use the hook in
order to accomplish the task of moving
the the blue object closer it can also
generalize to unseen tools and this is
by nature of the fact that it has a
large diverse data set also unseen tools
that aren't really conventional tools
like water bottles and because you're
sampling from both the demonstration the
action proposal distribution and the
random to
tribution I can also figure out when to
use a tool such as when there are two
objects that need to be pushed versus
wood not to use a tool when only a
single object needs to be pushed okay
cool so that was one aside on one way
that you might go about incorporating
demonstration data or incorporating
other forms of supervision in order to
perform more complex tasks the last kind
of approach that I'd like to talk about
with regard to image observations is
predicting alternative quality qualities
so it may be that you don't want to be
reconstructing images such as video
picture models and autoencoders and it
may be that you have some supervision or
some other axillary information that you
care about for performing your task and
in these contexts you can try to predict
those sorts of things so for example if
you want to be able to learn how to
grasp objects what you can do is that
given a sequence of actions you can
predict whether or not that sequence of
actions will lead to a grasp and so
given for example one of these these
yellow actions you can predict the
binary event of grasping or not grasping
and grasping is actually something they
could measure on the robot by looking at
how wide the whether or not after
performing those actions there are what
was actually holding something another
example is if you care about collision
avoidance you can predict given a
sequence of actions will I collide will
I hit an object and so if you have a
sensor that can measure whether or not
you've collided then this is something
you can predict relatively easily and
then you can also predict some things
like in a video game your health your
your damage or other information about
the environment so this is something
that's very nice if you don't want to in
these settings you don't have to
generate images this also has a very
close connection to key learning because
if you're predicting these types of
events that will happen if they were
happen in the future then you're
essentially trying to predict the
probability of some event happening
which may correspond to your reward
function if you care about whether or
not that event happens okay so the
benefits of this approach in general is
that you can only pretty it allows you
to only predict the task relevant
quantities and if you're in a multipass
setting
could predict the things like that are
relevant for different tasks the
downside is that you need to be able to
observe those quantities which isn't
true in the general case you don't
always know for example where objects
are or maybe if you are in a dialogue
setting you don't know the sentiment of
the other person automatically you don't
observe that automatically and of course
you also need to manually pick these
quantities that you think might be
relevant to your task ok cool so that
was all I had on model-based are all
with image observations let's see we
have 8 minutes I think we have time to
cover the last part rather than moving
into next week are there any questions
on this before I move on okay so what
about Maltese meta RL in some sense
we've already been doing some form of
meta ro and I'll talk about that in a
second so we talked a bit before about
how in many situations we have this
dynamics model that doesn't vary across
tasks and in these cases estimating them
all as a single task problem but what if
the dynamics are actually changing
across tasks and so for example if
you're interacting with objects and you
see an object on the table and you don't
know kind of a priori how that object is
going to move if you just see an image
of that object you don't know the center
of mass of the object you don't know the
friction and so you don't necessarily
know how it will actually move until you
start interacting with it in that
context it's actually somewhat of a
partially observed problem and you need
to actually adapt your model based off
of a small amount of data in order to
accurately predict how that object will
move and so you can essentially view
it's a dynamic start changing across
tasks you can actually turn model the
model learning problem from a supervised
learning problem into a meta learning
problem where you're now going to be
conditioning your model on some data and
then using that data to learn a better
model and in this context any of the
kind of meta learning approaches that we
talked about before could be applied to
this context so for example one meta
learning approach that we talked about
before is using
things like STM's or vowels with memory
and we were actually already using LST
M's
2 in recurrent models to make
predictions before so the those vision
based models they were you can simply
view them in this way and sense as a
meta learning problem because they're
taking in the context of the past few
frames and predicting into the future so
there's this somewhat of a blurred line
between what is what constitutes a
single model on what constitutes like a
medal earned model okay so one thing you
can do is simply kind of collect data if
you want to turn this into a meta
learning problem you can collect data in
different environments and adapt your
model to an environment given a small
amount of data and you can actually also
do this in a more online fashion so say
you have some robot that's interacting
in the environment and how's these
different different parts of the
environment how different dynamics such
as a terrain change or a motor
malfunction that causes the dynamics to
change now one of the things that you
can do is you can kind of flatten out
the experience of the robot and view
these different changes of dynamics is
happening in different points in time
and then if you take it if you take it
as viewpoint you can essentially view
the the few shot learning problem or
it's kind of the meta learning problem
as one of taking a slice taking a window
of time and using that slice of data to
predict what will happen in the
following slice of data so you can
essentially view this problem of
adapting your model or adapting to your
environment online as if you shot
learning problem where different tasks
correspond to different slices of
experience where basically for if you
have K time steps of experience this
might correspond to the training data
set for one task and the following K
time steps or n time steps may
correspond to the corresponding test set
for that task and then you can this is
one window of experience you can kind of
continuously slide that window to get
different
assuming you have some sort of temporal
continuity in the dynamics that you're
encountering okay so you can use this
you can basically use your favorite meta
learning method to solve this kind of
problem and so what this might look like
is that you have your last K time steps
of experience you then adapt your model
using your training data set and your
prior to learn a model that's
specifically adapted to those K points
in time and then use that model to
actually take actions and to plan using
MPC and so for example this update role
may correspond to one step of gradient
descent and theta star may correspond to
the initialization if you're using an
algorithm like mammal and so the way
this works is you may kind of collect
data on different terrains such as the
terrains shown here this is a little six
legged robot called the velocity and the
dynamics of the robot actually vary
drastically across different terrains
and across different battery levels and
then you can train it to be able to
estimate dynamics with only K times
experience where K is something like 8
time steps and that in practice
corresponds actually less than a second
of experience if you're around like 10
to 20 Hertz and then evaluate the robots
ability to adapt to other types of
dynamics like being on a slope or
missing a leg or having a payload or
having calibration errors and so what
you can see is that if you try to put
the robot on a narrow slope so here's a
visual of the slope up close if you try
to learn a single model across these
settings I what the robot will do is it
will I kind of diverge across it won't
be able to run in a straight lines that
won't have learned an accurate model
whereas if you use metal learning and
actually adapt online with each window
of experience to the current model and
use that to plan and run in a straight
line and you can also do something like
take off the front rent Lego the robot
and see if you try to fit a single model
it isn't able to model the dynamics of
these different situations whereas if
you train it to quickly adapt and then
use do that adaptation at a test time
then you can effectively follow a
straight line and so this was actually
getting back to one of the questions of
the B
the lecture where you're not only using
the observed state to replan but you're
also using the observed state to update
your model at every single time step
okay cool so I think that we're
basically out of time some takeaways for
model based versus model free learning
so some of the benefits of all based
learning is that it's very easy to
collect data in a scalable way without
wards it's pretty easy to transfer
across different reward functions
because it that model only depends on
the data it was trained on and it has a
less direct relationship on the reward
than the policy it also typically
requires a smaller amount of data or at
least a smaller amount of data that's
supervised based on the reward the
downsides of models is that they don't
optimize for task performance and so
there may be a mismatch and the optimize
the objective you're optimizing for and
the objective that you might care about
we saw the same thing in their
representation learning setting if we're
trying to learn a representation for
Reconstruction versus for the tasks that
we care about and sometimes is also hard
to learn the model than to learn the
policy such as in the pouring example
where you have have to model fluid
dynamics and then sometimes you may also
need assumptions to learn complex skills
such as the spatula example and then for
model free methods the benefits is that
it makes very little assumptions beyond
our award function it's very effective
for learning complex policies and
learning complex skills the downsides is
that it requires a lot of experience and
can be slower to learn and in the multi
task learning setting in particular it's
a harder optimization problem because I
have to learn a policy to perform all
the tasks rather than just learning a
model and inverting that model for an
individual task for each individual itas
you have a test time and then I guess
the last thing is that I don't think we
necessarily have this Toccata economy I
think that ultimately we probably want
elements of both such that when we're
pouring water we use a model free
approach and such that when we're
pushing objects around we have more
model-based approach okay in the next
few weeks I will be talking about this
is I guess the conclusion of some of the
RL section of the course and on Monday
and next week we'll be talking about
what about seeing tasks in sequence and
we'll cover this both in the supervisor
the reinforcement learning setting on
Wednesday will be have paper
presentations on some miscellaneous
topics that are interesting with
relating to task interference
differentiability sim to real methods
and hybrid reinforcement learning
methods and then the following three
lectures will be about really the
current frontiers of these approaches so
we'll have a guest lecture from Jeff
Clun who works on evolutionary methods
lifelong learning and meta learning I
will have a guest lecture from Sergei xi
on information theoretic exploration
approaches and how that can be used for
task agnostic reinforcement learning and
on Monday of a couple weeks after
Thanksgiving I'll be giving some
perspectives on some challenges and
frontiers of these topics and then just
a couple of reminders homework three is
due tonight and the project milestone is
to you next week
I'll see ya question yeah
for a symptom really I've actually seen
both used I've seen both model-based
methods to try to learn them all that's
robust to different different contexts
and then using that model to plan I've
also seen model free approaches and that
we'll see I think we'll see them all
free approach in the paper that's
covered on on Wednesday or on yet on
Wednesday next week yeah so there are
definitely very recent papers that have
looked at meta learning for some too
real where you try to instead of
learning a robust model you would try to
learn an adaptable model such as you can
adapt to any possible simulator and then
at test time you're given the real world
and you want to be able to adapt to the
real world
there's at least one paper that came out
in the last like two months that studied
metal learning for that problem so I
think that's kind of at the cusp of
where current research is that ok great
see everyone on Monday